so we've been having a series of
lectures for those who don't know the
briefie lectures are part-time
we are we want to give thanks to the
Frankie's for supporting this fantastic
endeavor what we end up doing we have a
group of students undergraduates who are
involved in a seminar called The Secret
Life of radio that I've been running
they've been wonderful students it's an
amazing seminar so far and as part of
that we get to bring wonderful guests to
come and sit it on the seminar to teach
us to read their work and to give a
public lecture so tonight I am thrilled
to get to introduce to you David Goan
who was a journalist a field recorder a
sound mixer and an expert listener with
a keen ear for auscultate and what might
be thought of as the fringes of mass
media radio in particular shortwave
radio and tyrant radio so in the seminar
today we focused on his work documenting
the history and the ongoing relevance of
pirate radio in Brooklyn about what she
was gonna speak tonight David's work
examines this ongoing role of radio to
cohere communities especially those
diaspora communities that have no place
that's officially allotted to them in
the media and David's work in ways that
are empathetic rigorous and ethical
shines a light on those communities that
fall between the cracks of FCC
regulation where individuals set up
small-scale transmitters to speak their
truth to share music and to disseminate
information about homelands distance and
local and refused to abrogate their
access to the airwaves so for those in
the audience I highly recommend
listening to radios to David's radio
documentaries on pirate radio I'm sure
you'll be talking a little bit about
this and pulling from it tonight and
visiting this amazing project called the
Brooklyn pirate radio sound map an
incredible online sound map that allows
you to sort of live in the world of the
Brooklyn's pirate radio it's a kind of
model I think in some ways of what
digital humanities and public humanities
could be doing the website functions as
both an archive of the sounds of
Brooklyn's pirates or micro broadcasters
as well as offering an experiential
interface that really lets you tune in
and get a sense of the geographic spread
of Brooklyn's pirate sounds David has
created programming for NPR's Lost and
Found sound series jazz Lincoln Center
afro-pop on the media as well as audio
based work audience installations for
Proteus kiwanis the ethnographic
terminalia collective and radio Kona and
over the past 25 years he's recorded
everyone from
as he says on his website the Dalai Lama
to the dancing chicken of Chinatown so a
brief list of some of his clients will
reveal for you how prolific and
in-demand he is he's worked for the BBC
the CBC NPR I guess radio loves acronyms
as much as Music Theory does he's done
for the la-based KCRW in KPCC and a bevy
of shows that are gonna be familiar to
anybody who listens to public radio such
as the world here in now marketplace etc
um it is really my pleasure to introduce
to you David Goren and we're so pleased
to have you here with us
[Applause]
gosh thanks Brian and thanks to Brian
for putting all this together in the
cash flow work for coordinating the
series on so honored and excited to be
part of this all the speakers in this
series have been influential to my
thinking about the many-worlds of radio
its influence on community and the need
for its preservation so my talk is
called tracing neighborhoods in the sky
New York City pirate radio every day in
New York City radio waves spill from
antennas connected to hidden
transmitters trend transgressing
physical and legal boundaries to rap
immigrant communities and threads of
invisible signal pirate radio acts as a
conduit bringing the sounds of the
ancestral home to a new home
transforming time space and culture
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- Rosie - hey I never attempted to you
yes sweetie music yeah we we from the
West Indies please let me know
Pynchon Grenada Spice Island children
it's a TV solution a solution
you listen to radio from whom here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that clip featured some of the IDS of
some of the prominent pirate radio
stations in Brooklyn and it also
featured DJ daddy lotto who was hanging
out on the street partying with his
friends one night in Flatbush Brooklyn
as I passed by walking down the street
the south of that Street rise into the
ether from pirate radio studios and
reflect down again onto tight-knit
communities they're often struggling
economically politically and because of
that are disconnected from access to
traditional media so what is pirate
radio there are homegrown radio stations
without a government license using the
government and radio industry would say
stealing the frequencies of local
licensed stations causing interference
to the licensed stations reducing the
range and revenue potentially blocking
emergency alert messages that those
stations are mandated to carry and knock
they are broadcasting those messages
themselves there are other potential
harms interference - air traffic control
and other public safety communications
unsafe radio frequency radiation from
the antennas and the buildings that they
operate in there's a debate over how far
these latter concerns go beyond
theoretical either way pirate radio is
illegal and that makes the people who
run them subject to penalty fines raids
possible arrests and jail time
the term pirate has been applied to
radio as far back as 1926 when a Chicago
station switched to a frequency reserved
for Canadian stations the government
called it wave piracy in 1960s Great
Britain there were offshore stations on
ships in response to new rock and roll
on the BBC and these were naturally
called pirates
pirate often but not always has been
used as a badge of honor
by unlicensed broadcasters here and also
in the UK is very active London scene
among the West Indian stations in New
York City I hear the term underground
used more often there were been other
terms bootleg in the early days of radio
often referred to a station that was
just imitating the format of a
commercial station and just sort of
pretending to be that station
clandestine controversial political
stations with anti-government messaging
free radio the 60s era and beyond micro
casting were applied in the 90s
progressive political movement so what
makes them illegal what's the mechanism
and subject to penalty it's the Federal
Communications Act of 1934 which
mandated licensing as a remedy for an
overcrowded broadcast band in the early
days of radio
so part there's part of the
Communications Act is called part 15
where you can actually legally operate a
station without a license but at such a
low power that the signal doesn't carry
more than like down the hallway running
enough power 1 watt 10 watts a hundred
Watts a thousand or more to reach your
neighborhood or small town without an
official license is in violation of the
Act I suspect that many pirates in New
York City think or hope that they're
legal under part 15 so here I have
appear there you go
this is from the FCC's site so this is
what section 301 of the Communications
Act of 34 prohibits the use or operation
of any apparatus for the transmission of
energy or communications or signals by
radio without a license issued by the
FCC and at the bottom they say the
Commission takes enforcement of section
301 seriously parties found operating
radio stations without FCC authorization
will be subject to a variety of
enforcement actions in
commuting seizure of equipment
imposition of monetary forfeitures in in
eligibility to hold any FCC license and
criminal penalties and one thing about
the Communications Act of 34 is it was
slanted toward licensing radio stations
operating his businesses making money by
selling advertising in the earlier days
of radio
there was a reform movement that saw
that it should be non-commercial and
available all different kinds of groups
and the commercial industry
there was really no commercial industry
it wasn't even thought that there was
commercial potential but through
networks you know banding together the
industry formed and thought that wow we
can make a lot of money so that the
Communications Act was tilted to
disfavor awarding licenses to special
interest and Community Rating groups
like unions religious organizations
other groups and in the words of
pyromania scholar John Anderson of DIY
media dotnet this led people into
radical acts like putting illegal
stations on the air so here's a
satellite map in New York City and as DJ
Danny Lauda said earlier there are a
thousand Caribbean stations in New York
City well not quite but there at least
60 or 70 almost as many as there are
illegal stations and adding in the other
broadcasters there's well over a hundred
in the Orthodox Jewish community there
are also several station then there's an
ongoing debate as to whether these are
anointed by God or a Shanda for the
[ __ ] as my grandmother would say so
take a look at the map I hear here the
the major general areas where there are
pirate radio stations in the Bronx which
is mostly latina --kx and West Indian
Queens which is latina --kx
and there is one Chinese language
station in Flushing then I'm aware of in
Brooklyn where there are well over 30
stations broadcasting every day to the
east to Flatbush and East Flatbush there
West Indian and a few Orthodox Jewish
stations and in New Jersey it's sort of
a mix
of those West Indian and Latina acts not
sure about the Jewish stations out there
so why do these station why do these
communities have these stations
generally it's the ones that have very
strong cultural historic ties to radio
New York City has a storied pirate radio
seen not just for the past 25 years
which is when these diverse community
oriented immigrant community oriented
stations started but it goes back to the
late 60s and a little later we'll check
that out and see what it was like then
and how and why it changed
this current phase of this particularly
grassroots community focused pirate
activity as I said goes back to the 90s
and it was sparked by the elimination of
low powered licenses under 100 watts in
the 1970s by the FCC public stations at
the time were encouraged to become
bigger and serve larger audiences
skyrocketing rates for media airtime in
the 90s
consolidation of formats after the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 was
passed which put no limits on the number
of stations of broadcaster code so they
were more inclined to you know leave out
the the smaller formats and that also
raised the cap from four stations to
eight that one single owner could have
in a major market the high costs of
starting a station which is in the
multiple millions of dollars even well
over a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred million dollars and few
frequencies available on an already
crowded dial combined with the
availability availability of cheap easy
to operator operate easy to operate
transmitters from China so you can get
on the air for maybe a thousand dollars
early or even less in the 90s there was
also a rising nationwide free radio or
micro casting movement started a little
earlier in the mid 80s that ignited
fast-growing neighborhood networks of
unlicensed stations many activists like
Stephen Dunn
free radio Berkeley made transmitters
and sent them out to people who would
start their own stations there were many
in Tampa there was a scene this guy LD
Brewer he was sent out stations and so
there were many different branded
stations San Francisco was another
hotbed of progressive political stations
and as I must of that movement was
anarchist radical progressive the
immigrant community focused pirates they
were somewhat separate from that
movement but they took energy well firm
up became a snowballing cross country
civil disobedience of likely 1,000
stations this was in the 90s after a
protracted period and court injunctions
the FCC finally offered a new low-power
a hundred watts or less licensed class
called LPFM low-power FM there was very
strong industry industry opposition from
the National Association of Broadcasters
the industry lobby group and sadly NPR
they really fought this hard and there
was a licensing window in the early
2000s and then it all kind of shut down
rules were would have put in place to
keep these stations out of the top five
markets so what happened was and also if
you were caught previously running a
power station you could not apply so
some people have said you know there
were like Rosa Parks but then they
couldn't take advantage of the new
freedoms there came about in terms of
the urban pirates the ones we're talking
about they were left out because of the
spacing rules
there was really no room for them so
they just kept on they generally did not
apply for low-power FM licenses so in
New York City you still have well over
100 stations on the air a kind of safety
in numbers and a bureaucratic and
underfunded system of FCC enforcement
keeps them on the air so who listens
what do they listen to and why is radio
still meaningful to them especially with
so many other choices in the digital
realm
[Music]
what's your local grocery store
and I always
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Cousy cuisine these underground
unlicensed pirate stations have been
around for as long as there's been radio
I came across it
every young age I was probably like
maybe three four or five years old and
there was this really popular station
back in the late 80s called Evangelina
and it was based on Brooklyn nobody
knows where it was their suspicions but
all I know is from Friday night all the
way to Sunday night you would just hear
a series of these stations every weekend
and
be the place where you can listen to the
latest in nation pop music Asian Wratten
is a it was also news like my parents
and their friends would all sit around
the radio and nobody speak politicking
in the living room get really loud
dancing singing along that's what I
think it was just like a meeting ground
and the radio was guiding it so it's
interested to be because the these four
listeners they relayed to the stations
in in different ways
angel Lopez their first guy there is it
works in my local bodega and he likes to
listen to he's from the Dominican
Republic and he likes to listen to the
Haitian stations because it reminds him
of an older form of merengue so and he
listens when he drives around and in a
way and this is true in a lot of New
York hit the bodega he works in it's
sort of like a radio station in and of
itself they have huge speakers and so
it's just sort of part of the culture
that he lives and works in the second
person is John Luke he's a drummer a
filmmaker from st. Lucia
he listens to locate himself within the
feeling of his neighborhood Haitian
stations for the French culture Jamaica
and Trinidad Ian for the dominant
Caribbean music styles and he actually
doesn't know or he didn't know when we
were talking that these are unlicensed
stations and he actually doubted that
they were when I told him about the
status because they just sound real and
authentic to him and that's a common
view twenty five years down the road
after these stations started they are
just accepted as being radio stations
they don't really think about it when
the FCC Commissioner who does not like
pirate radio stations talks about the
pirates he puts radio stations in quotes
but for these people there are no quotes
there they just feel real and John
Martinez grew up Haitian American and it
was just part of her life growing up and
it became to the point where she is on
she's been a broadcaster on several of
the stations
which developed through family
connections it's a very big family
feeling in the Haitian radio scene she's
working on a film about the stations for
her master's at Brooklyn College which
is in the zone of the stations and when
her professor of the aforementioned
pirate radio scholar John Anderson was
talking about the stations in class he
said I'm the one that well I'm on one of
those stations so she has a very keen
insight and there's her her logo and
we're gonna listen to what she has to
say about just the entirety of the
Brooklyn pirate radio scene all of a
sudden everything that was like Daddy
throughout the day and hear music hear
voices
[Music]
sometimes it's in Russian sometimes it's
Hebrew sometimes it's a preacher
sometimes the patient's spins Jamaican
what singing doesn't matter it's just
like a full moon
inspection and there's just something so
cozy about that you know because you
feel like when you're on the other end
of the spectrum it's like yeah this is
so American and this is so popular and
yeah that other sizing move another
perspective all people are talking about
it and talking about with honesty does
beauty when you wanna calm everything
Monday is everything cool cos orange it
almost be one side of a person once I
become a personality count one half the
capacity shot well it's like the radio
becomes like the second one
[Music]
and I really feel like the FCC really
John but I just feel like we intended to
kind of serve the community and because
you're not because you're relying on
corporations you want to hear a voice on
radio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why shouldn't you be welcome because
you're black because bro because you
give because because they are tricky
because the Nigerian why should you be
welcome to America
ooh so that's I think Joan describes it
she's very articulate and talking about
how it all comes together
in the skies above Flatbush so this is
the area that she's primarily listing in
Flatbush in East Flatbush in Brooklyn
and when you listen you will hear of the
major thoroughfares described Utica
Avenue Rogers Avenue in advertisements
and the deejays talking so there are
this is where there's the largest
concentration of Haitians in New York
City about over 90,000 and there's also
large to Macon and Trinidadian
populations and the content of the
pirate stations reflects that so this is
a chart I made a couple weeks ago every
hour between 7:00 a.m. and 8:00 p.m. I
made a scan of what I was hearing on the
FM dial so when I woke up they're a
little under 20 by mid-morning it was
down to seven and some of those stations
they don't even remember grabbing they
keep their silent signal on sort of
reserving the frequency so no one else
will jump on it and then it ticks up
during the afternoon and by between 5:30
and 7:30 many more come on and long
about 8 o'clock there's between 28 and
33 stations all broadcasting to this
small area of Brooklyn a lot of what
you'll hear during those hours our
newscast from Caribbean countries they
will run feeds from networks in Jamaica
and Trinidad in Haiti you can hear all
about the local elections in Grenada and
there's a like we heard a little stupid
of there's immigration advice shows
lawyers will come on and they'll take
calls and they'll update about what's
going on with that so I've been
listening in a concentrated way to the
way pirate radio
is used in Brooklyn particularly through
the several projects over the past five
years from my house in Brooklyn which is
somewhere around here so I'm in a really
good
zone to hear these stations and there's
a shape to it during the week this is
how it works during the weekend they are
on continuously from Friday night to
Sunday and then Monday morning the
station's switch off automatically
mostly when the people who run them and
the people who listen to them go to work
for the most part now we're going to
take a quick look at what a lot of my
research led to this is the Brooklyn
pirate radio sound map and this is
basically an archive of this the sounds
that I've been collecting and listening
to
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
yes that's Hebrew reggae dancehall this
was from a very short-lived Orthodox
Jewish station which tried to come on
the air and in less but if this is I'm
playing this to show that's the unusual
cross-cultural occurrence that that
you'll hear on the radio so I think of
the sound map is kind of a sonic
ethnography with a couple helpings of
journalism and several sides of soca
reggae Caribbean gospel music class and
klezmer and Sephardic Jewish music I
wanted to sketch the breath in the depth
of the soundscape created by the dozens
of unlicensed stations broadcasting
openly yet illegally in Brooklyn these
stations there they're not there by
design that they exist through a
combination of aspiration persistence
and need so the map shows the area that
the station's broadcast to I not showing
and I do not know unless I'd like so
there's an antenna on top of the
building I don't know where these
stations are broadcasting from and if
you look at some of the FCC data where
stations have been tracked and warned to
go off the air often they don't go off
the air but they get a warning sometimes
they're broadcasting from outside the
area in some cases from skyscrapers in
Manhattan you know with the antenna
hidden hidden somewhere so I'm trying to
be discreet about this information but
on the other hand it's a very public
scene you walk down the street you'll
see posters the stations give out phone
numbers they all have websites but I
felt like to preserve this information
was something that I wanted to do so
here's how it works so you can just use
the tuner it will load playing a sound
and
you can just click up and down the dial
[Music]
[Music]
there's another way that you can use the
map these are the main zones that
stations are broadcasting to the most
populous one is the one in the middle
Flatbush and you can click a list and
click a station and well tune on the
tuner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listen to you
so anyway so this is how you can use the
map it's I made it hopefully fun to play
with you there you can also as you play
it you can you can scroll back and forth
and listen to different parts of the
file and there's an archive button where
you can hear additional clips from the
station and I'm always adding to it I'm
seeking additional funding to improve
the map and and also to map the other
areas of the city so you might have
noticed that there are a lot of Haitian
stations
[Music]
so of the 30 plus stations
I can hear a knight at least a third of
them are broadcasting in Haitian Creole
as I mentioned earlier they're a very
large group group and Popish this is a
poster seen on the street and this is a
map of Little Haiti a recently
designated area in New York City
motivated in part by the increased
gentrification that's coming to Flatbush
so as to a opportunity to stake some
ground to try to enhance the community
identity so the Haitians
in Brooklyn they're actually well
established eat in the New York City
even before the pirate radio stations
there where these stations called system
they were running under a legal system
called the subsidiary communications
authority there will be a test on that
later and essentially that's a way that
these stations would least part of that
one of the two sidebands that support
the signal this is about as technical as
i'm going to get on a regular radio
station so they leased one of the side
bands and you need a special radio often
just tuned to that one station that you
obtained so these stations like radio
ponnu and radio show ma which is down
here at the bottom they started in the
late 80s towards the end of the Papa Doc
and baby doc regime and haney to bring
news to patients in Brooklyn Haitians
have been in New York City since the 60s
what happened was when the pirate radio
the new era was dawning in the 90s a lot
of the people who work for the
subcarriers got the cheap transmitters
and started their own stations so now
there's there's at least a dozen the
night that broadcast to this area so I
talked to this gentleman he's director
of
the Haitian studies at the City
University of New York CUNY were and he
is based at Brooklyn College which is in
the zone of these stations so I asked
him about the ties that Haitians have to
radio don't have money to buy tobacco
smoke but they will have money to buy
battery you know - because the one to
listen what Papa what what what to say
about many of those people because
remember the first generation of
migration the you know the big violation
was - in the nineteen sixties and many
of those people the culture transistor
was part order it with life so they
still
quite often this so for him you know
having a larger station it's very
important I'm inhaling itself they have
at least 300 licensed unlicensed
stations from what I've heard so it was
great to have contact with Joan and
learn more about the haitians team but
one problem I was having with this
project even though it's a very public
scene and and accessible in so many ways
was to get to people who were actually
running the stations and one day it just
sort of happened by accident I was out I
was recording on the street I was
talking to people like you know about
these stations and getting person on the
street style of interviews and then I
was standing on a street corner and this
guy called me over and he wanted to know
was i covering a recent gas strike a
hike in the prices which was causing
unrest in Haiti and I didn't know
anything about it from the traditional
media and then I said hanging do you
know about these stations
fathers and many of them actually don't
have a license thank you
so how important are these stations to
you forgetting the facts there are very
very important in our communities
certain news the main media will not
give it to us the job that we're doing
in this community we know they can erase
but most of the radio that you see the
cumulative is that making money we're
putting money remember all of the video
we put in money out we don't make money
on the video comedy
[Music]
[Music]
later that day I met up with Joan and we
listened through the stations and all
the Haitian stations had Collins with
people back home to act to try to find
out what was going on they also play
other roles in the community just have
told me that they find the elderly
people who have Alzheimer's who have
wandered away from home they he claims
that they broke up a gang among patient
Eames and set them on the right path
they raised funds for local causes and
for Haiti often boat rides throughout
the West Indian radio community are used
for fundraisers for fundraisers and
parties and Joan has told me that at the
end of these parties the station staff
tells the audience we are doing all this
for you and there is one more aspect
their sort of radio can operate as a
time machine and here's another quote
from Joan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's kind of like harkening back to
simpler time a better time so now we
have a sense of what the scene is like
today and I want to jump back to see or
the earlier era and and how it got to
today so back in the 70s and 80s the
dynamics were much different than they
are now the station's there were
stations on the air they were mostly
they were not like these they were not
targeted towards immigrant groups they
were there were just a few you know a
handful they operated late at night and
on a just a few sort of chosen pirate
frequencies now they're on left from the
bottom of the dial to the top in 1982
the New York Times counted about 12
stations citywide which was a lot really
for any city at that time the FCC was
much more active sorry about that and
they had monitoring posts and when they
heard a station they would they would go
after it so there was a lot of risk
involved
at the time listening to them it sort of
had a certain zing because when you
heard one it was like what's this doing
here
and it's like you know they could be
invaded while you're listening there you
know there was a really an Arab and
uncertainty stations they were mostly
run by young white guys electronic
adepts hippies hackers and they had
weird names and let's hear a little bit
of that I don't know why this is taking
us to SoundCloud but Wilco
[Music]
commonplace occurrences of day-to-day
radio there's one radio station that
will definitely stand out that's W
before B 87.9 input instead of smooth
professional commercial - radio you'll
get bad distorted buzzing sound a lousy
sounding muffled amateur get your Eagle
walk rate another words a completely
unique experience
[Music]
[Music]
so that's Alan there and he was sort of
like the Johnny Appleseed of pirate
radio he would go down to the storied
radio row in lower Manhattan on chamber
street by transmitters and hand them out
to people and they would loosely sort of
call themselves the falling star Network
so at one point late 60s early 70s he
and a friend were running two stations
24 hours a day in Yonkers New York and
then this happened
don't touch that dial I have the right
sound all
[Music]
[Music]
the stations were doing very well we're
on the air pretty much 24 hours a day
and then 5:30 in the morning on August
12 in the year of our Lord 1971 I had
all these federal agents piled into my
bed and wake me up basically saying Alan
reader get up you're under arrest
[Music]
and we went before a federal judge and
we pleaded guilty in collisions
Communications Act of 1934 as amended
the judge looked at us and said do you
realize what you did yes we were very
respectful he didn't find us and he
didn't give us any jail time but he
released us with a years probation he
encouraged us to seek out legal avenues
to be on the radio we didn't do that yet
anyway pretend you didn't hear that so
sorry about that hold on so anyway so
Allen left the scene leaving it to
others there was a sort of a code of
contact where it came along where the
station's didn't operate 24 hours a day
they would stick to the late hours they
followed what one station owner called
the Johnny Carson rule which is you
waited until the Johnny Carson talk show
went off the air and so you wouldn't be
interfering with your neighbors
television set and then they would go on
and broadcast all night then in 1987
Allen came back he was running a legal
station in Maine but he still had this
passion to get on the air in New York
City and he found the model of the
offshore stations in the UK and he
bought a boat called the Sarah he got a
lot of the Pirates who were broadcasting
at the time to throw in with him and
they started broadcasting in
international waters off of Jones Beach
Long Island and it didn't last very long
at all and they were busted after two
days there was an injunction he was
handcuffed on the deck along with a
reporter from The Village Voice and
after that he decided to go in buying
time a shortwave radio stations and a
lot of the
local pirates followed him and the ones
that didn't they stayed on the air in
New York City and and the scene kind of
started to fall apart there was a lot of
infighting people were snitching on each
other and that sort of created an
opening for for a new kind of pirate
radio sound so I noticed this starting
in and around 1995 it used to be as I
said that you would hear these stations
late at night and suddenly I started
hearing a station every night you know
early and they were playing hip-hop and
club music and it was called nasty radio
w jqr and it was run by an unemployed
neon sign maker of a Puerto Rican
background named Richie and on the air
he went by dr. X he changed a lot of the
rules aside from going on early and
every day he sold airtime to hip hop and
club DJs one of them was Dave Cintron
who was a UPS driver and he was inspired
by dr. X to start his own station
they do buy all kinds of gadgets and
build stuff and then he got comfortable
I was very fascinated with my radio and
he taught me some things and then he
sold me to churn
[Music]
this is a really big clunky transmittal
site all troops you know once I bought
that and Pokeno and then I started and
then I decided to call it you know so we
knew we were doing something else
we decided to call it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know the one who dreads thought one
reason Louis up man
you know we provided four or five hours
of just non-stop whoo all hip-hop that
people who just feeling for the time
well they didn't have to buy an exterior
they didn't have to go in around it
could just be whether they were having a
talk in a barbershop they're not a pop
shops
that's all the chocolate samples on you
know that's where you've got a lot of
love we were the only ones at that time
providing a simple platform for the
something music playing you take all the
very persons we will do like a touch
phone I would be in a car try to go as
far as I can see Melissa nice crispy you
know we would know what so they were
hitting talk about I would call us first
thing we will accent actually get so big
this is illegal you know they they come
back and on your doors less pretty much
what happened
Oh foreshadowing you can find out more I
tell you made a documentary about the
station which is on a great podcast
called lost notes from KCRW outlaws of
the airwaves so this is all this is an
article about wgr they actually w JK r
and w bi d which share the frequency and
this is where w JQ r was located and
this is was the main transmitter of w b
ad but by the end of their tenure they
actually had a connection to dren stars
apartment in the public housing in new
york city so they they it was actually a
pretty sophisticated operation so
towards towards the end of their tenure
on the air they the air wave started to
fill up and a lot of it was caribbean
oriented programming this was the dawn
of that scene and DJ sentronics he went
by the system that had been previously
established that if you were on a
frequency and 91 nine was the primary
frequency you were entitled to use it
you have seniority and that started to
break down big time
[Applause]
[Music]
we did and they actually you know and
they would actually told me this that DJ
syntonex and dr. X would Don like these
blue shirts and they wanted to give the
impression that they were actually from
the FCC and you know there wasn't it
wasn't you know they didn't act badly
they well except for cutting the wires
but but they what they wanted to do was
to talk to them and to say hey we were
on this frequency first but it got crazy
and and by the end
DJ sentronics would broadcast a dial
tone over the stations that were
interfering like so kind of jamming like
you know Moscow would do to the voice of
America and dr. X would get on the air
and start pretending like he was
preaching and then he would start
cursing and so they were just trying to
do all kinds of things to to get the
stations off but it was kind of a futile
battle so who was coming on the air all
these Caribbean stations and DJ D life
was an early New York City radio DJ and
he came on the air essentially or these
stations because there there were no
other outlets for Caribbean radio at the
time
[Music]
there was no mainstream radio station
giving you Caribbean music while the
mainstream left if you couldn't get the
transmitter and you can set it up why
not do it
the transmitters in the King easier they
are quiet and you started here with all
these different propositions
sometimes I would have to take my is
high with the energy in your go in 85
under gravity that's what we recorded it
will be popular in the backyard parties
and all the wasted employees it was only
so hard that they would approach and
approach there was no hesitation because
we didn't think it was something so a
lot of interesting things going on
you're very vibrant community but there
are harms to stations that we're running
legally and particularly unfortunately a
lot of these stations crowded into the
non-commercial band I think because they
thought these stations were less
threatening so I talked with the program
director of a beloved freeform radio
station WF mu and this is what he had to
say about trying to deal with what these
stations were doing
in one case I filed a complaint about
outside of New Jersey that was frequency
and it was operating not only as a
pirate using the non-commercial band but
they were operating commercially and
they were selling ads and it was a very
long running operation it's a pirate
radio station on the non-commercial band
that we're having as a commercial
business with impunity for years and I
had my FCC lawyer file a complaint to
make sure I did it right because I felt
like I have all the information on them
they were being so brazen about what
they were doing in terms of getting out
mailing addresses phone numbers and
website addresses and email addresses
and we filed a complaint and then we
found out that the FCC already knew
about them but they absolutely have
already received numerous complaints
about the same station so basically what
happened is so many stations came on the
air that it became impossible to enforce
so where they were taking Alan Wiener
out the air you know waking up 5:00 in
the morning there wasn't a whole lot
that they were able to do excuse me so
the FCC they have a map they show places
they're enforcing I think this probably
under counts things but in in New York
I'm sorry
well anyway well there we go
New York this counts a hundred and nine
that they've had taken some sort of
action what the action that they take
they do something they they they send
you if they find out and they are they
operate on a complaint basis so they get
a complaint and they use equipment to
try to track the station and then they
send that station a letter called the
notice of unauthorized operation which
says
we've noticed that you are operating a
station on this frequency if you have a
license for this station would you
please send it to us now I'm actually
interviewed the person to you for the
FCC I'm like you know they don't have a
license but they're still it's a
formality
that that they asked for and if you get
this notice and you go off the air
because you're worried then there's no
further nothing will happen you won't
get penalized if you stay on the air
then they send you the nal the notice of
assess liability so they'll say well
you're still in the air so we're finding
you ten thousand dollars for every day
that you're operating illegally usually
the operators ignore this or the pines
get negotiated down not a lot happens
sometimes there are raids on the station
but that's really very rare because
usually the FCC they don't want to go in
to the neighborhoods without like a
police escort the police there this is
not a priority for them to shut down
these stations what's happening now is
the new legislation and you know and
with the Trump administration of course
doing all these wonderful things to our
country the you know in the FCC whoever
the president is gets to appoint the
head of the Commission and now there is
[Music]
sorry they've been there so now we're
having a crackdown you know and there's
a commissioner Michael Riley who is very
fiercely opposed to these stations when
he refers to them in quotes stations
when he's talking about them so the FCC
is trying a number of things they put
they will find landlords who are hosting
equipment and they put pressure on
Congress and Congress now has an act
called the pirate act preventing illegal
radio abuse through enforcement they
like
ACK and acronyms and it's passed the
house and it's on its way to the Senate
it will raise fines to a hundred
thousand dollars a day with a cap of two
million dollars I still don't think
these stations are going to be able to
pay it it doesn't seem like it's has had
much effect at the moment and there you
can see at the bottom there is no
additional funding to do it to go after
these stations so I I think we're
probably just going to be I don't think
things are going to change very much
here are two different views from
rosemary Herald the chief of FCC
enforcement and Joseph from radio comedy
we're doing concentrated actions we're
trying our best to make sure that people
understand what we're doing and that
we're going out for folks who have been
found to be illegally operating stations
before and so that the message gets out
through the piratey through other means
and just because we're not so now we're
gonna look ahead to see what might
happen it's unclear - I see the the
number of stations is remaining high new
stations are coming on and that come
anyway
so I see the activity as being in its
mature phase I don't think the pirate
act is necessarily going to do that much
my thought is that gentrification will
probably do more to end the pirate scene
than any legislation in the
neighborhoods that the Pirates operate
in there's a lot of new buildings coming
up and
the character of the neighborhood may
may end up changing I'm just gonna
refresh this so I can get my sounds back
hold on
so a lot of the station's audience is
they're listing elsewhere anyway when I
have talked a lot of people in the
street they're listening on soundcloud
on YouTube and other means and when I
talk with trend star and DJ sentronics
they're like why are people even
listening to the stations anymore there
are so many ways but again I think it
comes down to the culture but it's an
open question are they still but you
know I don't think it's going to go
anywhere soon I talked to another
station on the Queens Brooklyn border
and they basically set up the station to
combat you know there's very sort of
crime-ridden area and they get on the
air and they get people to community
meetings they're the ones are they on
their Facebook page they're posing with
the police because they and the police
don't really realize that they're not a
legal station and they but they also
told me that I said well do you stream
also and they said yeah we actually we
get 50,000 listeners on our stream from
all over the world so I said so so why
are you still on the air why do you take
at least a theoretical risk of being on
these stations and this is what they
told me
what we bring to the table is something
a hundred percent clear our conscience
giving back to our community with the
current effects from X Y & Z Public
Safety to the good music from back in
the days but that's all we have we
didn't had enough to knows we had a
plate of white rice with to scramble
eggs because we can't even afford to
even buy a piece of chicken from the
grocery store that's how bad it was
cause and this radio station that we
provide to our local community is the
only thing that we can give back to them
a little bit of love a little bit of
passion
and a little bit of the Caribbean music
to make them at least feel good before
they hit the tool holder and pass away
because most of these people are in the
1780s they're the ones that are
listening to our radio station they can
call on to play with no shame you won't
do anything with to name all the guys
over to me that's what thank you
I made a documentary for the BBC World
Service which has as additional material
about the Pirates so any I'd be happy to
answer any questions
hi thank you some of them do have a talk
format I don't know I I think the pull
of music remains very high but if there
is a mix of talk like and political
discussions so so I think probably it'll
probably say the same as it is yes sir
thank you
that's a good question well for one
thing there you can get a printed list
of all the FM the legal FM radio
stations partly it's just because I'm a
super radio geek familiarity with the
dial so I know what's there and I know
what's not and generally the kind of
eclectic nature programming is not hurt
as much I mean New York City it's fairly
eclectic and you will hear music from
other cultures but but it's really rare
to hear soca
reggae dancehall so it stands out also
the quality of the stations is different
if you compare it to a legal station
they don't have like the same kind of
finishing processing so they have a bit
of a different sound to them
a sonic difference yeah
yeah that's right well as he sent him to
thing he said well because we were doing
something bad we called it a BB ad yeah
WH o t WF um and that day they were kind
of pranksters now you know it's sort of
there's RB storm radio there's triple
nine which happens to be on 99.9 so you
know there are often names that come
from the culture that they're operating
call hashalom is when the Sephardic
Jewish stations I've used the voice of
peace which actually alludes to a pirate
radio station that used to operate in
the 60s in Israel which was a
combination Palestinian and Jewish
operated station so it's usual marker
yes well usually it is within the range
although you can't hear it beyond the
range like I've gone to Queens to listen
to to see what the radio scene is like
there and it's largely stations
broadcasting in Spanish however I can
hear several of the more high-powered
stations from Flatbush which are kind of
bleeding in the Queen so radio state
radio signals know no boundaries so they
can they can you know they can go
wherever they go you know depending on
the power but usually the pirate opera
is they try to keep the power low enough
to serve a particular area but I've
heard pirate radius especially during
the day when the mass of stations are
not on and Flatbush like he
I can hear pirate stations from New
Jersey I've heard Ecuadorian stations
playing Andean type music I can hear
some stations from Queens but but
usually it's it's sort of served in the
area and when I was talking to Joseph a
radio comedy I said well you know some
people say that you know your your
transmitters malfunction and you
interfere with the airplane
communication they said we really try to
keep it low we try to avoid that we try
to keep
but just to the community that we're
serving that doesn't answer your
question okay great thanks yes they are
still on the air I recorded that last
November and they're still on the air so
there's a real kind of stasis in the
enforcement and again it's the
combination of the high number of
stations the bureaucratic nature of the
enforcement and the ease of getting on
the air it's relatively inexpensive the
stations the stations do go off the air
on something like oh well you know what
happened to this station and the a
pastor at a church station he told me he
actually said well you know I'll talk to
you but I don't want to go on the record
because our antenna was just taken down
and I want to go back on the air so I
don't want to call in tension myself I'm
gonna wait three months and I'm gonna go
back on and that usually seems to be
what happened they lay low for a while
and they get new equipment and go back
on and chose this radio comedy also told
me the same thing they have to they move
they find another place you know that
they are basement that they have to rent
and so they're just always like trying
that's their strategy they go off and
then come back on it's a good question
they're probably I would mention it
anywhere from 10 watts to a hundred
watts or maybe even more in some cases
I've heard some enforcement people and
some other people think maybe even a
thousand watts which is really a very
powerful station and that's where you
might get some concerns about if there's
a hidden transmitter on a roof it's
spewing radio frequency radiation and
that's potential concern but you know
it's on a roof and there's concrete and
so it's hard to know you know it's not a
50,000 watt station like wmic where
there are signs like don't go near the
transmitter now but you know there are
third it's I think they're fascinating
and they perform a service but you know
there are problems it's a complicated
issue
yes well I'm a big fan and I and I
definitely support their stations and
they're there akin to wfm you they're
really they're trying to hang on and so
if a pirate station is in their
territory then it can especially
stations that just they don't advertise
but they raise funds through you know if
their audience the smaller it makes it
harder for them John Anderson the pirate
radio expert he advocates something like
a harm reduction program where instead
of taking the Pirates off the air you
would go out to them and you would say
here's how to operate more cleanly you
know you're interfering with so-and-so
maybe you could turn turn this down or
get a new transmitter or something like
that but I'm you know I loved those
stations and I'm definitely supportive
of them anyone else
yes
she can stream them online so you could
you could look at the names on the map
and you could you can find most of them
have websites out or their or they have
Facebook pages so she could listen that
way but they would not go as far there
are you know aside from New York City
Boston to Miami which are big stones
there are stations up and down i-95 when
we were driving up from Brooklyn
yesterday 87 9 is actually a good place
to look because it's just below the dial
and I heard three or four different
stations popping in and out of 87 nine
yes I've heard about it and I think that
definitely happens and the FCC will say
on their site you know with this is a
pernicious problem now particularly
because stations can be mobile so I know
in the in the shortwave radio pirate
realm which is a little bit different
there are mobile stations you know they
put a antenna on the car and they move
here and they move there I think also
stations are moving their antennas
physically they'll take down an antenna
here and they'll put it over there
VPN equivalents are like a proxy so you
can wander the wave like ventriloquism
yeah yeah I mean you can certainly do
that in the legal broadcasting realm you
know do remotes I think it happens I
don't know of any concrete examples but
I'm pretty sure that happens yeah I've
heard of things like that too yeah give
me tell me how to reach those guys
anyone else
it's early
[Music]
yeah it definitely happens and it's
happened historically in in London for
years there's been a very active scene
you know behind grime music and it's
still going on it seems to be tailing
off a little because actually the their
equivalent at the FCC has been offering
kind of like a carrot and stick like if
you go off the hare will give you a
frequency but the meaning of landscape
is a little bit different in when I
talked to Kim Freedman of wfm you he was
in in Paris in the like the early
seventies and there were what they
called free radio stations everywhere in
in South America it's interesting
because a lot of there's not that much
official community radio and there are
pirate radio stations and they are sort
of allowed to exist in a gray area
because there are sort of fulfilling a
function and something similar some
people feel that during the Obama here
there was recognition within the FCC
that this there was a problem but they
were serving audiences that were not
otherwise served so as joseph said
during the Obama years we had a good
break and now we're running every other
week so yeah not that I'm going in China
there's a different kind of situation
where stations from outside China will
broadcast to China like religious groups
of Warcraft's from Taiwan there's
something called the voice of hope and
there's also especially in countries
that may have a restricted media other
countries like Germany with Deutsche
Welle and The Voice of America in the
United States the BBC will set up sort
of like a proxy broadcasting into that
country by shortwave by AM and FM you
know they can be jammed
but jamming is not absolute you can open
here through a jam signal Russia I'm not
sure I'm not sure yes
you know we knew who was doing this we
tracked them down with all the
sophistication that is there no way to
track these people and have their wires
yeah you can but probably can't Freeman
doesn't like when I do something that
might get him in trouble or in a violent
situation you know I if it's possible it
could happen sometimes the station goes
off you know I don't know why why did
the station go off also I don't think I
mentioned this Joan of the the Haitian
radio community says that the stations
will quote narc on each other so they
will turn each other in because they're
essentially competing for the same
audience that sometimes they'll have
fights on the air and one partner will
leave in a huff so it's it's possible
but but I don't know I haven't I haven't
seen concrete proof of that yeah also I
call up the Brooklyn Twitter pirate Ross
he he calls the interference of WL from
you morally repugnant
he is really some people are really
upset so I think some people are so
upset it's possible that's something
like that could happen because all you
need you need a radio direction finder
it's not impossible to find these I walk
through your neighborhood just with a
regular radio and suddenly I hear
interference and you know Abby though
it's probably around here so we were
really motivated you might be able to
find it
thank you so much yes
do you spend time actually listening to
them are you more interested in kind of
discovery no I definitely listen to them
a lot you know I'll greet I mean I
record them and I go through like I'll
you know gee are they on all night you
know so I'll run the thing I'll find out
when they go on and off and you know
I'll look for IDs because a lot of them
don't really ID so some of them are
recording is to figure out what's going
on but yeah I listen to them and you
know some of the programming is really
quite interesting and it's just sort of
a shame that the media policy is broken
that these people have no access to get
on the airwaves even when they really
want to so that the FCC you know was a
Bureau of interesting hyperlocal radio
then then these stations would be
performing a good service but but
they're you know they're breaking the
law
in the eyes of the FCC so yeah I
listened to them I'm really I mean part
of my documentaries and work is what I
find interesting about them and so I'm
trying to showcase the programming yeah
and some people are angry that I you
know I'm trying to approach it
objectively and show the good in the bad
I was asked to do when the map came out
I was asked to do like it has a
questions for an interesting article
called radio Hank and so I said what the
map was about and someone a program
director at Emerson University's radio
station said David Goren should be
prosecuted for even making it sound like
there's anything worthwhile about these
stations so so I'm turning myself in
tonight
they are they definitely are but you
know it's hard to quantify how many
people are listening not sure some
people I talked to say I don't know what
you're talking about
and some people say oh you know I kind
of know that but I don't really know the
name or oh I thought that was a legal
station you know so there's different
levels of knowledge within the community
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]